this week on quadriga terror in nigeria
world to the rescue
global condemnation has followed the
release of a video that shows some of
the kidnapped nigerian schoolgirls
it's been a month since they disappeared
and in that time pressure has piled and
nigeria's president good luck jonathan
to act
his government has accepted help from
abroad to save the girls
the u.s has sent advisors and
reconnaissance planes like this one to
aid the search
but along with the anguish over the
girls fate there are also some voices
criticizing the help from abroad
they say it's a dangerous extension of
the war on terror
is foreign assistance the right answer
to islamist terror in nigeria
your host this week melinda crane
hello and welcome to quadriga
why has the nigerian government done so
little to rescue the girls is it unable
or unwilling to do more and does
worldwide public outrage really make a
difference that's what we want to talk
about today on the program with three
experts who follow events in africa very
closely and i'm pleased to introduce
peter durie he reports on africa with a
focus on resource politics and security
issues for publications such such as
think africa press and veltz
welcome to you
and john ameka akuda comes from nigeria
he has served as an advisor at germany's
ministry for economic cooperation and
development and he's currently working
with the german development institute
researching conflict and conflict
management in africa
and finally it's a pleasure to welcome
my colleague zainab ahmed hamid she's a
journalist from nigeria who works with
deutsche bella's africa desk she's a
coordinator for the learning by ear
program which spotlights social issues
affecting the lives of young people in
africa
zainab as i understand you have just
come back from nigeria a week ago you
know we've seen pictures of the
distressed parents uh we hear about
worldwide outrage what are others in
nigeria saying what's the feeling there
in your region it is in the north you
you live not more than about a hundred
kilometers away from the village the
girls are from tell us uh what what was
the sentiment that you encountered
um um the entire northeastern region in
nigeria is a kind of
kayaking now especially these three
states that have been placed under
emergency rule talking about adamawa
borno and ub state
and
since before the happening of the
abduction of these girls
people have been living in fear
in fear of seeing military
it's not easy you see the military
within the cities moving among people
stopping cars on the way within cities
not in the bush but within cities
militaries are no also military are
known to be in
the bar at the barracks they stay in the
barracks normally we have the policemen
and we have the ssa they are normally
within the people we are used to them
and all of a sudden
now the military is all over and uh
people get scared even seen those
uniformed people with their big guns you
know moving within people within the
civilians it's not normal in the markets
you see them on the street you see them
then
came this
sudden abduction of these girls and
the situation became more and more
fearful you can see it on the faces of
people nigerians are living
in a kind of
situation which i can say uh
laughing and then continue living you
know
it's because the situation is so so so
so
beautiful when you think that
it is not your daughter it is not my
daughter but you think as a parent
as a
as
somebody community member when you think
that
these girls are ambitious girls they
have their goals they are just in their
teenage and then they were there
to seek for education to seek for their
future
and then of course all of a sudden
overnight they were taken away in loris
how would you feel
just hearing that these ambitious girls
are just gone
and they are gone they don't know where
they are they don't know what situation
they are in that is the fear that is
what what happens to you next what
happens to the neighbors what happens to
the villages what happens to people
not just those girls that are left but
to you that is living in the same area
what comes next that is the fear between
working within nigerians now especially
in those areas janakuda what about anger
fear clearly what about anger are people
frustrated how could it be that after so
many weeks we still don't know where
these girls are
you know people are angry
people are frustrated
but this
anger and frustration
you know did not just start with the
kidnapping of these girls
you know um
zenav just said something about um what
fella you know fellaini collaborative
and you know this popular musician that
once died you know called suffering and
smiling i think it was a record he
released sometime in the 70s so
where he was saying that nigerians are
suffering and in the midst of suffering
they are smiling so just to say that
this issue of fear and anger is not new
it's always been there because of um
you know irresponsible governance
which goes back to corruption
so um all these things are now happening
because of you know the long history of
irresponsible governance that we have
had until now you know and one hopes
that
this might be you know a catalyst you
know for um
the ruling classes in nigeria to really
um think about what they're doing to the
society you know she talked also about
fear um you see people are afraid not
just afraid of
of you know the terrorists but also
afraid of the security agents afraid of
the army afraid of the police because
they have a tradition of misuse and
abuse of powers i mean a lot of people
are languishing in nigerian prisons for
doing nothing i have once been arrested
and detained overnight for doing nothing
just for waiting on the street you know
um just to tell the story short i
visited a friend who was in lagos in
abuja the friend was not there
a rich man was in a very big house so
the wife left me in the in the sitting
room and went upstairs after a while it
was boring for me so i told her that i
want to go outside you know and wait
outside
in nigeria for the rich people it's
normal that they have security men we
call them megats you know outside the
house
and most of these security men have a
table where they sell sweets and
cigarettes and things like that so i
went out outside the gate to stay with
this security man on the table where he
was selling something this was happening
in 1992
in ikeja lagos suddenly um
it was a police vehicle in the arrested
young man in the streets i was just
looking at it and you know discussing
with the security man what is happening
here and suddenly a policeman came to me
and asked me what i was doing here i
told him i was waiting for my friend the
sister's house and things like that he
asked for my identity card i was already
doing my phd at university of benin at
the time i gave him my identity card he
said yeah i mean you have a lot of um
fake identity cards uh that has to take
me to the police station to confirm that
i ended up spending a night and was
lucky to be released the next day
because i saw a policeman that is a
neighbor to me whom i just called
through the window and told him what was
happening he went to his boss and after
about 30 minutes to one hour i was
released so a lot of people get you know
killed in police cells and things like
that so i mean this is not in you so
fear and anger um
good luck jonathan the president of
nigeria elected just a couple of years
ago vowed to change all that but you're
both telling me there's still a
tremendous amount of government
irresponsibility
i ask you peter derry
could the government have found out more
about where the girls are
should it have undertaken some form of
rescue not by now and could it are we
talking about incompetence are we
talking about political a lack of
political will and perhaps even
something darker
um it's probably a combination of the
above
the first thing to mention is that there
are several reports that say that the
that the village where the gold schools
was situated and where the girls were
taken
that was attacked and
the before
the
the assailants came to the school to
take the girls away um there were was
about a four-hour time frame where the
army could have come in and um and saved
the girls basically and they didn't and
i think there was a just an amnesty
international report that came out
that basically said there was the
opportunity uh to save these girls
before they were in there and they uh
they were abducted um but the army just
didn't do anything and how do you
explain that it is often rumored in
nigeria that the army may even have
contacts to boko haram that it may even
be providing them with weapons do you
think this is a case of outright
conspiracy in some parts yes so i think
it's pretty well established that
at least
in some cases there have been dealings
between
the army and
boko haram but for that to understand
it's also important that boko haram is
not one movement
it used to be
but uh then um as the conflict between
the government and boko haram were
grew longer and longer and i mean this
is going on for years now um the group
has splintered and is very diverse um so
there is there are allegations and i
think that some of them are well-founded
that uh politicians and parts of the
military establishment have cooperated
at times with parts of of the group we
know as boko haram
for political reasons or just for plain
corruption
would you agree with those allegations
rumor has it that the military officers
in nigeria
see some personal profit in letting the
conflict continue because they have the
biggest military budget they have ever
had and a lot of it apparently flows
into their own pockets do you think
that's right
well i would not say outrightly that is
right because
the experts and
maybe some of the opposition party
officials have accused the military of
using you know this huge budget they
have because the security budget is so
huge that
it's unbelievable this amount of money
and nobody is accounted for
they don't account for the money when
you budget for security for a country
this in nigeria is for example there's
no accountability for that so the expert
has some experts and some analysts are
saying that
the military
sometimes they instigate these things
that are happening
so that this budget will keep on growing
and
the top officers you know are getting
this money but the
one fact still remains that the lower
military those that are on ground those
that are within the society those that i
kept on the road
checking points and what a few these are
people that when you see them you will
know that these people are in absolute
hunger
they are in absolute poverty
is either they are not
what they are supposed to be giving you
are taken away from your deity post and
to a special duty post you are supposed
to be giving a special allowance
so they end up doing other things that
they are not supposed to do as a
security agent
so we have seen recently in my degree
burnout state where the military
attacked
their commander there just within the
week simply because they claim that they
have not been paid their allowances they
have
so this kind of thing if the military or
i can say these lower officers can
attack their senior officers then you
will see that there's a lot of
things that are not really clear there
are so many things happening in there it
sounds like sounds like those underpaid
soldiers might be potential recruits for
a group like boko haram of course
you know
it is possible that they are especially
um if you juxtapose that with the
information we have that since boko
haram has uh um really gone into an
alliance with the al-qaeda in in the
maghreb and that they have been having a
real financial sponsorship
from
saudi arabia and from london great
britain um
you know so if
if you put these things together then
you see that
if you have a situation of you know
unpaid military people and the situation
of well-financed
terror group
then it's possible that um there could
be you know a change of camps um but i
want to say something again on the issue
of collusion um you know um of
complicity between the military officers
the high level yeah the point is that i
mean if you understand the political
economy of governance in nigeria uh you
have to understand that it's about money
you know so um
it is uh very very plausible
that
this increased military budgets
end up
in private pockets of top military
generals
and because of that the um you know food
soldiers are very angry
and that is why most times they don't
attack boko haram when they are sent to
attack boko haram because they will tell
you we cannot do this on empty hands
we'll be risking our lives that is one
again on the complicity um i think it
was like two years ago
when a joint task force was sent to um
attack boko haram
um
they ended up being killed the soldiers
because
it was clear that boko haram had the
information
that they were being that they were to
be attacked at a certain time
and they got prepared laid ambush for
the soldiers the soldiers walked into
the ambush without knowing and boko
haram killed all of them which means
that i mean there is an information
going on between you know coming from
nigerian military to boko haram now if
you listen to um
the um in the last video uh messages of
this leader new leader of the book of
haram last week
he was saying that he wants to exchange
these girls
with the boko haram members that are in
prison and he said exactly
where those
prisons are located in which cities
these prisons are located i mean i
researched on nigeria i don't know where
these things are
me some nigerians so just don't even
know where this is in which particular
frequencies yeah so he's got specific
information from the military so i mean
these things are very clear now peter
during the government has finally said
this week it is willing to talk to boko
haram about a possible exchange of those
boko haram prisoners being held by the
government for a release of the girls
should it could it have opened those
negotiations much much sooner why just
this week um it certainly should have
because i don't think that there's
really a military solution to that
hostage crisis it's
it's bound to end in bloodshed if if
they try to rescue these girls with
military means um it should have opened
up to this possibility earlier but i
think there's also a past history with
negotiations with boko haram there so
they the government tried several times
um to
at several points to negotiate a truce
with boko haram and
for one reason or another all these
times it they failed
sometimes because boko haram wasn't a
joint movement that could be negotiated
with its or at other times that because
the government itself wasn't very
uh united um in about the idea of
negotiating with such group um and i
think this is the same thing what
happened now the president was very fast
and saying no we won't negotiate with
terrorists because he wanted to be to
appear strong and he wanted to show that
they that he has control
although he obviously hasn't and um yeah
so now there's a change of heart when
you see that there's some
they realize that they don't have the
situation under control so they tried
next best option and say well maybe you
can we can negotiate
let's focus a bit i see you want to make
a comment but perhaps also focus a bit
on boko haram itself we've just heard
john tell us it is a terrorist movement
it is associated with al-qaeda so should
the government actually then engage in
negotiations but is it a terrorist
movement for you
for me um it started like a sect
which had a particular aim or goal to
achieve that was in 2009 when they came
as agitating for sharia in the northern
nigeria they wanted sheridan to be
implemented islamic laws
that was what they first said that was
what and we knew then it was just one
group with a particular aim
and
at that time
there was
a lot of they started these attacks not
exactly as it is now but somehow they
came out and then
they were known to the government who
their leader was who was
caught by the military and given to the
police and there he was killed in the
police custody that we know muhammad
yusuf
and since then everything went down
before again
it came up with other we hear boko haram
with different faces nobody really knew
whether this is one group but it is like
this is it emancipated you know with
different in different angles with
different motifs
different attacks they started with
bombing the churches
which ordinarily
nigeria is not divided along religious
or ethnical line we are all united
nigeria is a one nation we don't look if
you look at did not i have to say i just
want to briefly interrupt you i see john
nodding his head now as i know you are
muslim you are christian exactly and we
unite together regardless of your
religion or your tribe because nigeria
has multi
you know languages we have a lot of
languages we have the major two
religions and other traditions but we
live together we live in unity
and if you look at northeast where these
things are happening
majority of the families are
mixed you hardly find a family which has
pure muslims as members or pure
christian as members so if you're
fighting a christian
let's say i have i'm a muslim and all
the other family members am i going to
kill my brothers am i going to kill my
cousins or my nephews i can't do that so
that is
when it came when they started bombing
the churches now they started saying
okay they want the implementation of
sharia but the sharia they said they
wanted to implement the then mohammed
issue and his members were muslims only
it affects only the muslims in the north
because no christian would do something
against the law and he will maybe
when he's caught with corruption or any
other thing his hand will be amputated
or something like that but it only
affects the muslims there but with the
killing of muhammad yusuf everybody told
everything was dead and it became quiet
until when everything erupted again in
different ways and it will surprise you
to know that most of these places that
have been attacked in borno and yobe
these are
areas that are muslim-dominated areas
when you check the local government and
the
neighboring local they are all
muslim-dominated places so who is boko
haram that is the question of china and
the question many people are asking
themselves is is boko haram abu bakar
we've all seen pictures now he appears
to be a crazed fanatic but janakura if
he were only that surely boko haram
would not be as powerful as it is so
what role does he play in all of this
and and is this a sect is it a an
emerging civil war army what exactly how
can we understand what boko haram is
thank you very much i don't think um
this might lead to any civil war but the
issue is that boko haram if you are you
talking about boko haram are you talking
of a massive that is the movement for
the actualization of the sovereign state
of biafra are you talking of opc in the
west are you talking of
the mend you know the terrorist groups
in
niger delta you see all these groups are
protest groups and they are protesting
against one thing
bad irresponsible and negligent
governance in nigeria period
um
i wouldn't want to you know dwell on
that because i think that's that's very
clear the issue of you know the
increased violence in of boko haram has
to do with grievances caused by the
extrajudicial killing of the first
leader of boko haram who died in police
custody without even being arraigned
before a normal court of justice you
know so this kind of um
aggrieved a lot of people and not only
that you know um after this um issue of
members of boko haram
laying ambush and killing soldiers
you know
soldiers and police people went back
and killed all the people that have been
arrested arrested as members of boko
haram that we are in police custody you
know just brought them out and killed
them so what i'm saying is if you act
like this
you know you are kind of increasing the
grievances in the society against the
system
and look at the name boku haram it
simply says
uh um
we reject western education we reject
western civilization we reject western
um you know system why do they do that
because you know nigerian system is a
western system the education the
government governance the economy
everything is western and this is a
system that dehumanizes human beings
that makes them very very hopeless so
it's not like there is no basis for what
they are saying we have to bear this in
mind coming to the personality just to
say something
yeah one or two studies about about the
personality so the killing of yusuf um
the prior leader yeah
before that before that everybody knew
how insane
insanely radical
this shakai has been
yusuf has had a terrible time trying to
hold shaking in check
because he knew what he was going to do
and suddenly yusuf was killed
and shakai disappeared went on the
ground the story was that he was dead
and suddenly he you know recovered and
you know put up this group together and
started so
it is the removal illegal removal of a
moderate gave the chance to a crazy
radical to do what he's doing now
okay so we have a really poisonous
mixture here from the description that
we've just heard we have a lot of people
who are angry and who are frustrated and
fearful and clearly who can in this
vacuum of governance fall prey to a lot
of different splinter movements
including some very extreme ones peter
dory connect all of that for us please
to the fact that nigeria is now africa's
most powerful economy according to the
latest statistics a very resource-rich
country
what's going on
um yeah i think what what john has
already alluded to and the nigerian gov
economy is
very powerful the the country is rich
you can say that there's a lot of oil
and there are a lot of mineral resources
which haven't even been tapped yet and
it's mostly about oil at the moment and
there's also quite a strong economy
apart from the oil sector right now so
you have a film economy and
and you have a telecommunications sector
and everything so there is money
but
this money stays at the top it floats to
the top
there are politicians there are
uh big men getting rich
but very very little of it trickles down
to the broader population and i think
that north east is a is among the worst
off
uh parts in this country where boko
haram of course
has exactly
raging so would you go so far as to say
that nigeria is on its way to fragile
state status i mean you could may i i
wanted to make this point about the
civil war question you could make the
argument that there is already a civil
war i mean with with all
around 2 000 people dead since the
beginning of this year with more than 5
000 dead over the last few years um
there's an argument to be made that this
it is already a civil war in some ways
and i don't think that you can talk
about the whole of nigeria but i think
parts of the country are real are
certainly fragile
or fragile parts of the state
and i mean boko haram at one point
before the latest army offensive
there were
huge parts of of the northeast where the
government virtually had no influence so
there was no army presence there there
was no uh a government presence and you
had boko haram actually controlling
parts of the con of the countryside um
so yeah i would say that there's there's
there are some elements of a fragile
state there yeah so
muhammad is this a situation in which it
makes sense to send
military support even of the indirect
kind that the u.s is now providing it
has sent some reconnaissance aircraft
the head of africa com has now gone to
nigeria to talk to the government
is
western military support the right tool
to use our quest our title asks the
question world to the rescue is that the
kind of of means by which we can rescue
these girls
i don't think so and um when you look at
what
the experts are seeing regarding this
you know foreign assistance to nigeria
which some taught
that nigeria should have sought for this
assistant long before now even before
everything escalated to this position
while some are saying we don't really
need nigeria doesn't really need this
foreign assistance because
you're inviting people from outside
we should look at the geographical
location of northeastern nigeria
especially borno where this thing
happened
which is why they are inviting the
foreign
military now to command assist of
foreign expat
so some are saying that
if you invite people from outside of
course they have the technical know-how
of locating
maybe using the modern technology to
locate where these people are
in these very forests and visa they say
they are located they have the technical
know-how better than nigeria that is
okay if you are inviting that help but
not military on ground
you don't invite military on ground to
nigeria because
nigerians have confidence
in the military because uh building
military in nigeria had had reputation
of helping other peacekeeping missions
in other countries outside nigeria
especially in west africa
so i think
among the military people that are
posted in these areas there are people
from those geographical zones and they
know the locations they know those
places better than anybody that will
come from even other parts of the
country not talk of somebody coming from
outside
while um
some of the oppositions are saying
that when you bring military now you're
inviting more trouble
as we have seen in other countries so we
need the technical assistance of
assisting nigeria knowing the situation
of our technical know-how which is very
low when you compare to the western
world united states
france
which led to the meeting that is going
to take place at the weekend which the
france is hosting
so i think
i will somehow agree with them that
military intervention is not the best
but technical know-how will help nigeria
do you agree john would you say what
what is the best kind of outside help
that could be provided right now yeah of
course uh i will agree with the zainab
that uh you know um what we need is
technical help and not military help in
that sense um uh i have said that
technical help and military help helper
often uh that's
a very clean line i mean technical in
the in the area of
surveillance you know um technical in
the sense that um you know since oil has
been discovered
uh in a lot of countries in the guinea
coast in the west african coast
um
and again coupled with uh you know um
al qaeda in the maghreb
um you have a lot of american spies
american secret agents for several years
now you know patrolling this area
collecting information so what i have
once reading on the facebook page of a
blogger uh who happens to be a cousin of
mine a law a method is that um you know
what nigeria and that was about last
year even two years ago what nigeria
needed to do was to seek help from the
us and possibly from france because they
have their secret agents here and the
secret agents have information that we
don't have let's say that let's say the
government actually does get some
information through these unmanned
surveillance aircraft or or from spies
from whomever
peter durry told us a few minutes ago
listen if this turns into a military
operation it's going to be a bloodbath
yeah i don't think you know this will
not automatically turn into a military
operation i mean if you get information
then you know how to use information to
really um get at the people you're
looking at so
it's not really going to uh um become a
military operation depending on how you
manage that um i will just just um you
know excuse me to say one or two things
you know about this concept of them in a
fragile state because i mean and that's
the area where i wrote my doctorate work
and i've been lecturing at the
university of cologne you know on this
issue for several years now um
nigeria you know has been displaying you
know the classical you know futures of a
very fragile state it's not a collapsed
state but it's um definitely very very
fragile you know so we have to look at
it as that and since this government
government took over things have even
become worse we've never really had good
leadership in nigeria and this bad
leadership is getting worse and so peter
durie if
we do have surveillance aircraft
providing some details those details are
in some way handed over to the
government will it inevitably turn into
a military operation uh not inevitably
but um there is i think there's a real
danger that uh for example the u.s now
has manned surveillance aircraft um in
in in the over in the area and they try
to find the location of these girls and
i'm pretty sure that they are capable of
doing so um but likely there will be
multiple locations so nobody if
the leader of boko haram is in his right
mind he will have split up the girls
into multiple locations and this will
will make
a hostage rescue by military means
incredibly difficult and
i think
the the danger is that
the us or another state shares some
intel with the uh nigerian government or
parts of the nigerian government and
wanting to be to appear strong and
wanting to bring a quick solution to
this crisis that makes them appear in a
very in a very bad light they they
take the decision of trying to rescue
these girls and i uh maybe they do it in
cooperation with the u.s special forces
maybe they try to do it on their own but
um i don't think that it will
end well in that case so i think there's
they would i know
of a cooperating state i would be very
very careful what information to share
with the nigerian government in this
situation i'd like to take a look now at
another type of help or support the
world has been trying to provide namely
the global twitter campaign
the hashtag bring back our girls has
become a huge trend on social media
it sparked rallies around the world with
several prominent people supporting the
campaign
u.s first lady michelle obama posted a
photograph of herself with the hashtag
on her twitter account
she also took over her husband's weekly
presidential address to speak about her
outrage over the schoolgirls abduction
the hashtag has contributed to global
awareness about the kidnapping but it's
also been slammed as mere online
activism that has no effect on the real
world will the hashtag campaign help
find the girls or is it destined to fade
away and be forgotten
what do you think zynab
does it help does it make a difference
well um
it might help because i'm sure if
the leader of boko haram sheikha can
upload
a 15-minute
you know
video
and send it to youtube which everybody
can see i think he sees what is
happening
and i was watching some of the nigerian
medias yesterday
the campaigners who have been sitting
there wearing red holding the black card
bringing back our girls campaigning
calling on the government to do more
calling on the society to help calling
on the security to help in bringing back
the girls safe and sound
they were there
last night i cried i i i had tears in my
eyes what some of them were seeing the
campaigners what they were talking about
these girls and i'm definitely sure
wherever he is
the leader of boko haram and his members
who are
holding these girls they must see what
is happening they must see how the
entire world
is saying they should bring back those
girls please they should bring them but
and
might and um
sheikau actually draw exactly the
opposite conclusion if he is as
fanatical as he seems to be mightn't he
simply say uh john nikuda um wow this
has been a tremendous success for me i
have the whole world's attention and the
west hates what i'm doing yeah and that
is you're really correct and and that is
my fear uh because it's not just uh i'm
reduced to sheikah and the boko haram uh
you know international terrorism as we
know it um you know studies have shown
that
and they feed on on the media reports
you know they want to intimidate
societies uh um you know um with with
fear and
they do this through media reports so
once you have a lot of media
i mean it's playing into their hands
and that is my fear that you know all
these campaigns um you know will make
him happy and hurting him the more
but again i will say that if this
campaign is what it is need what is
needed
to you know get nigerian government to
be concerned about this case
then it is positive on that side don't
forget that it took about three weeks
before the nigerian government reacted
to this issue and within these three
weeks that these girls were being looked
for
the the daughter of nigerian president
got married and he was you know at the
ceremony dancing you know i was looking
at it dancing at the marriage of your
daughter
where about 250 or 300 families are
losing their own daughters you know that
is one and then to come to the
international campaign of you know um
this big politicians
cameron obama you know um
it is good that if
you see the cause of these problems as i
say goes back to corruption
which deviates the attention of people
in governance and from government and
most of the stolen monies
are left in western banks in britain in
the u.s in in um switzerland and
wherever so if cameron and obama
do not see a connection between the
money stolen by nigerian governments
present and past that are in the banks
in their countries and this kidnapped
girls if they don't see a connection it
means they don't understand the world
they claim to be leading if they see a
connection and do nothing and just run
around with play cats it is clear
hypocrisy
so if there's leverage from a campaign
like this it's not going to be on boko
haram and chicago itself if anything may
be counterproductive but perhaps on the
government according to what we just
heard peter durie
when i look at the campaign i'm reminded
of what we call
in international law the right to
protect
an evolving international principle the
idea that there are some circumstances
where countries outside need to go in
because the government simply isn't able
to protect its own people a principle
that uh vladimir putin has lately been
abusing
with his own rhetoric but a principle
basically devised after rwanda when the
world sat by and watched another horror
in africa is there a right to protect
issue here and is there something the
international community can do besides
twitter
um
there
no i don't think that you have a
responsibility to protect case in this
in in in this instance because um
you have a state that in theory would be
capable of uh um of dealing with the
situation because it has the the means
to do so it has a strong military it has
the funds um so they could deal with it
if they could get their act together um
and it's also not the case that you had
that that it was a state who abducted
these 200 girls um so there there's a
bit of a different case
to something like rwanda or central
african republic so i don't want to mix
these things up um
as i said uh there's i don't think that
the military intervention from the
outside or from the nigerian military in
this case would do any good and so this
is out of the question for me um
and there's
uh and also there's a question of
practicability so uh what what what do
you want to do do you want a u.n mission
to uh northern nigeria
when we when the u.n barely gets the the
congo under control so you would need 20
25 30 000 u.n soldiers if you want to
match the scale of the commitment that
the nigerian government has in place and
it's just not just a question of being
remotely practical to intervene on this
scale to say okay the nigerian
government can't handle it we do it from
the outside and also i agree with john
it's an it's the root causes of this
issue are in nigeria and no
no amount of in outside intervention
will solve this problem so you have the
nigerian government in algerian society
has to has to get a grip on this problem
no outside help will
will change anything fundamentally there
very briefly if you would zainab
muhammad
from everything that i've heard this is
a very complex and a very long-term
problem and we've got a short-term
crisis
what needs to happen now briefly
um actually what is happening the major
thing that is happening now is the
inconsistency even among the top
government officials in nigeria
the good luck jonathan just said they
are not going to accept
the request of the boko haram releasing
their members in exchange for the girls
abducted
and the
president of the senate who is visiting
in china also conquered what good luck
jonathan said yesterday when the
commonwealth minister in charge of
africa mark simon was based in nigeria
and
his the information minister said they
are going to discuss they are going into
dialogue with boko haram so there's a
lot of inconsistencies but what is
important here is that this common unity
among the engineers to fight the common
enemy thank you very much for being here
with us today thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in
you